[موسيقى]
مسابح معايا من عمري عشر سنين
انا مع ابوي بذيك الفتره كلهم يعني اللي
عندها سبحه وعند مقام عندما موقع عنده كذا
في البلد
فشوف ابوي يروح على سباح انا صرت نفس
الشيء هو يمد ايده سبحانه اخذ وحده ومن
يشوفني اخذتها ما يريد يزعجني ما يريد
يزعلني اخذها رغم انه عدم قناعته بيها بس
انا اخذها مثلا هاي البيضه هاي السبحه
هي
على بساطتها كما هي والحمد لله يعني انا
سمعتز بها لانها مع ابويا
اكثر وحده تفضلها هذه
اماكن تعرف لان الاصناف مجرد عجبي بيها
[موسيقى]
يعني استمرت عليها الشغله هذه شفت فيها
حلوه اسافر اول ما اشتري اشتري سبحه كويت
مصر سوري لبنان
قبرص السعوديه
صارت كميه ما شاء الله من غير اللي راح
مستمر لحد الان حاليا اتونس وقت اللي ما
عندي شيء فراغ اتونس بيهن اقلبهن اجددهن
وهكذا صارت كميه
[موسيقى]
من اقوم اسبح بها التهي بيها انسى المصيبه
او المشكله او القضيه اللي عندي
هذه طول عمره لحد وفاته هو يستعمل هذه
ابويا
فهذه عزيزه علي
السبحه جزء من تراثنا
يعني كل واحد
جزء من تراثه عنده سبحه كل ما تصير السبحه
دائمه عند مستمر معها ما يبدلها دائما
نادرا ما يبدل السبحه متعود على وحده يسبح
بها خلاص من يطلع ماخذ السبحه
[موسيقى]
عندي مجموعتين من السباحه
القسم اللي مختاره غاليه الثمن وهذه نوع
من الموجود من عندي يسر ابيض مشغول بالفضه
ويسر اسود مشغول بالفضه
وهذا كهرمان اكو موجود
حاج ابيض
وازار مرجان
لؤلؤ اسود
لؤلؤ ابيض قسم تيجي هدايا من البشر من
الناس اللي رايحين لمكه
هذي مثلا يعني رخيصه ما لها قيمه بس عندي
من صار جدي صار لها قيمه
حافظها واتذكر منه جاب لي اياها اصدقائي
اقربائي
او على مجال الشغل
سبح مختلفه الاسعار
يعني ما اتعامل معها على اساس سعرها لا
اتعامل معها انها سبحه موجوده عندي جزء من
صارت جزء من عندي هذه السبحه انقطعت من
كثر الاستعمال ما في شيء
اذا يتحمل انه عقده او انه يعيد
تركيبه وحده وحده
[موسيقى]
بس مجرد اشوفه يعني ذكرني بعمري انا اليوم
سته وسبعين سنه
انا عشر سنوات
عمر يعني
فارق بين احداث اشكال
احداث مفرحه احداث مزعجه والسبحه جزء من
عندي
اغلبنا هذه مثل ما
البس شو اقول هذه حلقه مال زواجي ما
انزعها السبحه معايا نفس الشيء
[موسيقى]